le moment des décisions difficiles est
venu on trouve qu'on mérite mieux que
mais n'est-ce pas dire qu'avec ses
déclarations à l'emporte-pièce une
claque en plein visage sais pas ce qui
va nous faire travailler plus souvent on
fait travailler mieux on peut pas tout
avoir brandi une attaque directe contre
la classe moyenne contre la politique
familiale s'assurer que le régime
recourt plus être préservé
chacun va l'envoyer mince
on termine l'année avec un bilan la
semaine dernière on a fait la scène
fédérale ce soir c'est au tour de la
politique québécoise
dans notre dernière table ronde de la
saison aussi gâtés ils sont maintenant
en studio michel tâche à daniel bonsoir
lança l'idée que vous soyez là sont
assez de déchaîner d'ailleurs pour ça on
a dû alors on voulait pas être sérieux
ce soir non plus donc on va faire ça par
catégorie 1re catégorie l'événement
marquantes de l'année pour vous
messieurs pour moi ça a été le 20e
anniversaire de la tuerie polytechnique
à l'assemblée nationale sa vie il ya pas
beaucoup de raisons de croire en la
politique c'est ainsi quand j'ai vu les
femmes députés à l'assemblée nationale
se lever une à une pour lire le très
beau texte de françoise guénette devant
tous leurs collègues qui étaient des
rendements étranglée par l'émotion
tu me suis dis qu'il ya peut-être encore
de l'espoir avec la politique et tout ça
a débouché sur la promesse de maintien
du registre des armes à feu
très honnêtement en 30 50 couvertures de
l'assemblée nationale je pense j'avais
jamais vécu un moment qu'ils recelaient
autant d'émotion alors c'est pour moi ça
a été l'événement d'arc émotionnel
c'était l'élection finalement et la
défaite du parti québécois est la montée
du parti libéral qui est entraînée plein
de conséquences on voit maintenant la
course à la chefferie du parti québécois
qui aussi va changer le décor c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui misaient que
sur sont souvent marquant mais quelque
chose qui a changé la donne on
s'attendait pas un résultat comme ça et
on vit maintenant avec un programme
complètement différent que ce qu'on
aurait eu sous le parti québécois
la course a commencé puis ça
complètement gens exactement daniel
votre événement un autre événement qui a
changé aussi la donne politique qui a
peut-être mis la table avec eux
l'arrivée de pierre karl péladeau c'est
le débat sur la charte de valeurs ça a
été un débat d'une rare intensité comme
on ne l'a jamais vu même pendant les
périodes de référence r je suis pas
certain que c'était aussi intense avec
les débordements inévitable est ce que
est ce que ça a contribué directement ou
indirectement à la défaite du parti
québécois ça n'a sûrement pas aidé ce
pas été le facteur principal le stade a
sûrement pas idée ça reste que c'est un
débat qui s'annonce important que toutes
les sociétés vont devoir faire même au
canada on remet de plus en plus en
question le multiculturalisme
la question que je me pose pas ce que
fait les couilles à tiendra sa promesse
et relancera ce débat
moi j'ai des doutes on reviendra sur la
charte parce qu'elle revient dans
plusieurs catégories cette année donc on
passe à la deuxième catégorie le
policier le plus performant d'achat à
moi ça va avec mon choix électoral c'est
monsieur couillard au début de l'année
je pense qu'on s'attendait pas justement
avec la charte des valeurs et toute la
controverse là-dedans qu il performe
aussi bien qu'il l'a fait pendant
l'élection est aussi je pense que il a
été aussi sévères ou aussi fort lors de
la présentation de l'austérité c'est pas
un programme qui est populaire on voit
toutes les manifestations tous les jours
mais je trouve que comparativement qu'en
ontario où on vit une situation
complètement différente on voit que il
joue l'homme fort de la politique comme
on ne s'attendait pas alors c'est bon
politicien d'année on aime ou on aime
pas martin coiteux présidente du conseil
du trésor
oui il ya une face à claques mais il est
dépité il a parfois l'air arrogant il a
parfois l'air suffisant de manquer de
compassion il sait exactement où il sort
il a des idées les défend très bien à un
président du conseil du trésor c'est pas
un poste qui vous permet de gagner des
concours de popularité il va pas en
gagner loin de là sauf que il sait où il
s'en va il fait penser vous savez à qui
à stéphane dion qui a encaissé dans sa
vie des tonnes de coûts de tous ses
adversaires même de ses amis mais qui
est toujours resté fidèle à ses
principes sans y déroger de ryota mais
c'est intéressant parce que michel
oui monsieur quoique il ya un côté de
l'ag que détestable et qui
personnellement m'agace profondément mai
dois reconnaître que monsieur équateur
surtout pour un gars qui a absolument
aucune expérience politique qui débarque
comme ça qui se voit confier ce qui est
dans son la mission numéro un du
gouvernement kouyaté qui performent
extraordinairement l'assemblée nationale
et qui pour la première fois depuis je
sais pas combien d'années réussi à
contenir la progression des dépenses
publiques il ya aucun président du
conseil du trésor qui réussit depuis dix
ans et sur papier mais jusqu'à présent
il ya des espèces de contrôle périodique
ça tient maintenant monsieur kouakou
encore amplement le temps de se casser
la figure d'ici la fin du mandat mais
pour cette première session je trouve
qu'il a magnifiquement performé
donc on continue le politicien le moins
performant le cancre de la classe
orienter vos réponses
daniel vous y parviendrez à éclairer
votre jeu que ministre de l'éducation à
conquereuil c'est pas un mot que j'aime
mais bon le moins performant il s'est
mis les pieds dans les plats souvent
c'est presque une catastrophe ambulante
monsieur balzac
il est vraiment pas fait pour
l'éducation tous les premiers ministres
ont des mini ce dont il voudrait bien se
débarrasser jean charest penser à jean
charest avec la yves séguin avec thomas
mulcair français a fallu que ma voix
avec daniel breton
il ya des ministres qui fonctionne pas
pour des raisons d' incompétence et
réseau de personnalités mais il a eu
raison
mais c'est pas des décisions faciles à
prendre est-ce qu on les fout carrément
à la porte
est-ce qu on rétrograde yves beaulieu
qu'est-ce qu'on la voit sur l'arrière
banc complètement dehors restant non il
y aura des conséquences c'est du coup
hiératique non mais je suis sûr que tu
as les couilles attendant temps des
fêtes ont multiplié les 9èmes des
rosaires des prières les patterns et
sert pour que monsieur beau jake
s'améliore pas si vous êtes téléphoner
mais je crois malheureusement pas
l'amélioration du tout dans cette
je pense que monsieur couillard n'y
crois pas non plus pour les raisons
suivantes on l'entendait aujourd'hui là
il confie à monsieur bolduc la
préparation d'une politique jusqu'en
2025 savez quand on envoie quelqu'un aux
projets spéciaux là ça veut dire qu'on
veut sortir de
gestion quotidienne du ministère et je
peux vous assurer que ça sera pas
monsieur beaulieu qui vont être assis à
table avec les enseignants pour négocier
la convention collective et monsieur
vous dit que c'est en fait presque pitié
mais monsieur couillard est un peu
responsable
il a voulu faire une place gaétan
barrette
il attend c'est monsieur bolduc et
pourquoi lui faire de peine ou un
américain s'est dit je vais vous donner
quelque chose d'à peu près équivalent
alors là c'est il n'a que lui même à
blâmer
tasha mois encore c'est pauline marois
aurait bien élections parce que encore
c'est la donne qui a changé les
solutions moment je suis consistant il
avait le choix quand faire cette
élection on pensait tous qu'il allait
mener les élections sur le dos de la
charte des valeurs que tu as mentionné
plus tôt était vraiment son projet le
plus grand de la dernière année de son
mandat et que ce qui est arrivé c'est
complètement tombé à l'eau et la jouer
sur la souveraineté on a eu les
exclamations de monsieur péladeau et la
fille le fameux shove lors de la
conférence de presse pour lui tassé du
micro et l'a mal gérée la preuve poing
levé la hes-so lui ment et satu
dégringolé alors s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
mal performé vraiment c'était michel
vous n'êtes pas sûr qu'on était génial
comme campagne c'est drôle parce que
justement quand elle est assez peu la
douche tous meilleurs coups de feu y
aller rendement parce qu'on n'y arrivera
pas sinon que catherine parmi les
dossiers délicats compliqué et puis je
verrai quelle est la patate chaude
michel on a parlé d'un toulalan estime
me semble être était il demeure la
patate chaude
on l'a vu madame marois fondamentaux
avec certainement choucas finit
finalement pas parlé pendant campagne
électorale depuis que le gouvernement
couillard est en place il y avait promis
un projet de loi pour le printemps le
yacht trouve une raison pourquoi le
présenter cet automne on se demande
qu'est ce qui va trouver pour pas le
présenter au printemps prochain
et ça va être aussi une patate chaude
pour le parti québécois là
monsieur rainville nous dit qu'il va
ramener une charte modifié qu'est ce que
les autres vont dire de ça ils ont déjà
commencé à 110 stations à prouver est-ce
que la caq vous dis bah moi je peux pas
laisser partir de revel où le pq tout
seul avec la laïcité ça va demeurer une
patate chaude pendant la prochaine année
l'achat moi c'est l'austérité à la façon
que ça a été géré dans au tout début où
on avait les commissions scolaires les
conservatoires tout le monde se lance
elle a peut-être non qu'on veut pas la
voir ici on veut pas la voir là
finalement le gouvernement auquel on y
compterait exactement on peut pas se
décider où couper purement gouvernance
est décidé et on voit maintenant les
l'impopularité de la chose mais au moins
des décisions ont été prises de façon
organisée mais au début c'était un peu
embarrassant je trouvais daniel la
patate chaude que celle du parti
québécois qui s'appelle bien edel à dos
et yobe
il ya des patates chaudes qui deviennent
des catastrophes il y en a d'autres qui
deviennent de grands succès à pierre
karl péladeau c'est sûrement la recrue
politique dans plus prestigieuse depuis
on a parlé tout à l'heure lucien
bouchard probablement sauf que il fait
pas des choses comme les autres qui fait
pas la politique comme les autres
il fait toujours à sa tête de cochon si
je te reprends mon expression préférée
et et même à l'intérieur du parti ils
feront peut-être pas l'unanimité
facilement s'ils refusent de participer
au débat ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
lui en vouloir il ya une aile syndicales
au pq qui a beaucoup de problèmes avec
les ados donc pour le parti ça va être
gros dossiers à gérer il ya bien géré
jusqu'au mois de mai intéressant le bon
coup de l'année tâche à moi c'était un
bon coup pour la population et je fais
référence au passage la loi sur la fin
de vie le projet de véronique hivon qui
a eu l'approbation universelle de tous
les partis qui a aussi maintenant
pousser un style de clôture fédéral tu
as montré un projet exactement comme ça
je trouve que c'était un rare moment où
on a vu que tous les acteurs politiques
ajusté dans le bien moi c'est le bape et
tous ces gens qui souvent avec un
langage agaçant de les tories qui des
fois m'agace mais qui ont réussi à faire
au sens de freiner l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste la construction d'un
terminus re
le méthane un port méthanier à cannes et
à un moment où il ya des tonnes d'études
scientifiques traître un crédit qui nous
parle de catastrophe à venir si on fait
rien je trouve mais ces décisions là
sont très intéressantes alors que très
souvent les deux david heurtel de ce
monde improvise pas l'impression que ça
va être autre où ils s'en vont en ce
sont deux décisions qui étaient très
rares à toi aussi aux nouveaux besoins
qu'on l'a vu aujourd'hui michel votre
bon coin est le bon coup mon bon coup
c'est le deuxième débat de françois
legault
souvenez vous racontera la grappa
électorale jusque là la caq aller nulle
part
tout le monde se disait si fini legault
il va finir avec dix députés puis voit
s'en aller il va faire autre chose et il
l'a tellement bien performé dans ce
débat là qu'il ya eu un renversement en
fin de campagne qui a permis à la caq de
finir avec un score finalement tout à
fait honorable et qui a permis à
monsieur legault de se donner une autre
chance
on verra ce que ça donnera mais ç'a
vraiment été un tournant pour la
campagne et pour la carrière politique
de monsieur legault qui se serait
arrêtée là
s'il avait manqué cent des voix c'est
vrai c'est bien intéressant l'année 2014
a aussi donné droit à des prises de bec
assez épique
alors on a ajouté une catégorie de
l'attaqué la plus virulente de l'année
daniel celle des syndicats contre
l'austérité
ça a commencé avec le saccage de l'hôtel
de ville de montréal il y a eu et vous
allez me dire c'est dans la nature des
syndicats c'est le rôle qu'ils ont à
jouer mais un flot absolument incroyable
de déclarations intempestives on avait
parfois l'impression que le québec qui
était à feu et à sang que le québec
était devenue la grèce que tous les
hôpitaux et toutes les écoles allait
fermer quelques uns qui sera débarqué au
québec certaines journées depuis deux
mois se serait dit mais mon dieu que
bien qu'étant très disparaît beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'exagération michel
mois celle attaques de jean françois
lisée compères karl péladeau porte
qu'elle était particulièrement virulente
mais les taxis dieuze et monsieur lisais
je pense c'est rendu un très mauvais
service en lui même
sur le fond il a raison je pense que la
plupart des gens s'entendent dire qu'il
ya tout le moins un problème on sait pas
comment régler mais il ya un problème
mais pour monsieur lisez qu'on
s'attendait quand même voir faire une
assez bonne figure dans une course à la
succession de madame marois is equally
complètement et je pense que monsieur
l'elysée voit le regretter longtemps
on verra alors tâche à ces attaques est
aussi la volte-face de gaétan barrette
on savait tous c'était le gros
bulldozers qui avait négocié en faveur
des médecins l'homme la plus grande
augmentation historiquement parlant et
la devenu un ministre de la santé bout
et change la donne et il repousse contre
les médecins exactement ce qui leur
avait obtenu alors c'était peut-être
même une trahison je sais pas mais
c'était sa virulence de ce changement de
position de cette attaque ma surprise
pas aussi consistants que vous on peut
pas tout cela alors qu'elle devrait être
la résolution de philippe couillard en
2004 j'ai commencé avec vous michel si
vous aviez un conseil à donner à
philippe couillard et j'ai entendu dire
qu'il lisait vos chroniques avec
assiduité avec plaisir aussi binger j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait déjà fait un bon
pas dans la bonne direction en entrevue
qui se disant que maintenant il va
parler français quand il va se promener
à l'extérieur ce qui est déjà une très
bonne résolution mais j'irai un peu plus
loin si j'étais lui je serais beaucoup
plus affirmatif dans la spécificité du
québec et dans l'autonomie du québec
face à ottawa face au reste du canada
savait robert bourassa day a personne
qui peut gouverner le québec sans une
bonne dose de nationaliste jean charest
même fini par comprendre si monsieur
couillard ne le comprends pas il va
avoir de gros problèmes
pense aller jusqu'au bout parce que
l'austérité ce n'est pas facile ce n'est
pas populaire mais c'est nécessaire et
ça donne un exemple au reste du canada
comment ça peut se faire si on crée la
grogne et la grogne malgré les
manifestations si on continue jusqu'au
puy de nelle si vous avez un conseil
quelques émissions conseil se trouve un
ministre de l'éducation se trouvaient
des ménages et 10 ont une vocation qui
vont faire en sorte qu'on va chasser
l'idée que ce gouvernement-là improvise
et 3com 10h à maintenir le cap sur
l'assainissement et sur la création
d'emplois développement d'économies
c'est ce qui va le mettre à l'abri dans
quatre ans il réussit de pierre karl
péladeau bon alors voilà on l'a fait ce
bilan politique est ce qu'on vous
souhaite à vous pour 2015 des élections
fédérales on va en avoir en soit le vrai
course à la direction du pq encore
quelques mois les spéculations qui se
passe beaucoup de choses
je souhaite une élection au fédéral sur
les grandes questions comment discuter
la semaine passée pas une élection sur
les personnalités alors bavoux 3 vous
souhaite de bonnes vacances de joyeuses
fêtes on vous remercie d'être ici avec
nous chaque jeudi parce que nos
constructeurs mois on l'apprécient
beaucoup nous si nous fait c'est mieux
comprendre la politique puis c'est
vraiment un plaisir de te la mesure
vraiment peur peur ici on se retrouve
l'année prochaine est déjà fait